welcome to the program we're still
learning about an incident that took
place this morning in New York City a
lot of it is still being figured out we
do have some details there was an
explosion in the Manhattan borough of
New York City this morning in the sort
of underpass or walkway between 42nd and
8th Avenue and 42nd and 7th Avenue sort
of between the Port Authority bus
terminal and the Times Square subway
stops in New York City this is all very
close to Madison Square Garden and it
was a pipe-bomb or sort of home made a
person mounted explosive that went off
and when this happened Port Authority
was temporarily shut down and for people
who are not familiar with this part of
New York City or Manhattan or New York
City in general you have in Manhattan 2
major subway and transit stops one is
8th Avenue and 42nd Street and 42nd
Street of course indicative of sort of
like the north-south location in
Manhattan 8th Avenue to the west of 7th
Avenue that's also a big subway stop for
the blue lines the AC and e lines in
Manhattan and then 7th Avenue and 42nd
Street which is one long block to the
east is another major subway and public
transit stop where you have three other
subway lines the red lines the one two
and three and because these two major
subway stations are just one block apart
there's this underpass that connects the
two underground and I would use this
frequently when transferring from the
blue to red lines are red to blue lines
in Manhattan and it is very very crowded
in there particularly at rush hour which
is when this took place and the the news
as of now is that there's one person in
custody and four injuries it appears
that it that one of those four injuries
is the individual who is in custody who
blew up this bomb and he has been outed
or identified by police as the term
probably better is said as 27-year 27
year old Akkad
and the belief is that the individual
acted alone it is still early in all of
this but the sort of mo certainly fits
what we've seen under the umbrella of
allegiances to radical Islamic groups
often no operational connection
whatsoever but someone that we at some
point find out seem to have pledged
loyalty to one or another radical
Islamic group sometimes the radical
Islamic groups attempting to actually
take credit for the incidents although
very often it seems that while there is
sort of a shared ideology that there
there is no actual operational
connection which makes it no better or
worse it's absolutely horrible the the
real good news here and it's very hard
to say that there's any good news when
you have such a crowded key
transportation hub the victimized by an
attempt at absolute total chaos and
terrorism is that only four people are
injured here whether or not that
includes the the alleged perpetrator
okay yet Allah the twenty seven-year-old
it's not totally clear it's very early
in this story we may already know more
by the time you listen to today's show
or watch today's program and I don't
want to inflame fears irrationally or
give anybody ideas but this is a serious
program where we talk about the the
realities as we see them about a lot of
these important issues including
terrorism and I've said it before I've
been concerned about the lack of
security at transit stations in and
around the United States and around the
world really for many many years and
that doesn't mean that I have a
particular solution to this problem but
I've pointed out that when you look at
what has been going on with airplane
terror and what has been done to at
least attempt to harden up airplanes and
airports as targets much of it not
working particularly well when you see
how poorly the self-tests of the TSA go
I've been pointing out for a long time
that subways and subway stations buses
and bus stations in Europe more
relevantly trains and train stations
where train is a much more common method
inspiration I have a fear and I don't
think it's an irrational fear I still
recognize that statistically we are all
very unlikely to ever be the victims of
terror but I do have a fear that
increasingly places like Grand Central
Station in New York City Penn Station in
New York City and places all over the
world that are equivalents to those are
prime targets with the potential for
massive damage to be done and that there
really is not any significant security
now the counter to this is well if
you're going to heart if you're going to
do what you've done in airports at every
bus station and every subway station and
every train station you are moving
closer to the security state under the
guise of the global war on terror that
is exactly what we might say a win for
the terrorists because it would
completely upend the commutes of
millions and millions of people so I I
don't know what the answer is but what
I'm telling you is that this is
something I've been concerned about for
a long time now as far as today's
incident we'll learn more probably by
tomorrow
this guy's explosive was crudely made
from what's been reported so far he
ended up doing the most damage to
himself only and that's good but this is
still a very serious issue and it's
important not to go overboard right
that's the important thing
statistically you are still very
unlikely to ever ever be the victim of a
terrorist attack you're way more likely
to die by handgun or by car accident so
I'm not saying this to stoke unnecessary
fear but within the category of
deliberate acts of terror this is and
has been a major concern of mine for a
very long time the video you just
finished watching was made possible by
you through the membership program you
can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership